today I want to talk to two different
groups of people one are the employers
the CEOs founders that would like to
hire veterans former military folks Army
Air Force Navy Marines but you don't
necessarily know how to connect with
them and you don't know a lot of their
challenges they face when they
transition from military to civilian
life that's gonna be for you the second
group of people I'm talking to are the
actual veterans you may be watching the
same Pat I'm about to eat tears a month
from now six months from now 12 months
from now I have no idea what I'm gonna
do I keep going to different things but
I honestly don't have any clue what's
gonna happen I am absolutely concerned
today we're going to talk about the
transitions what challenges you guys
face when you make your transition I was
at 101st Airborne Division I know what
it is to go from military to civilian
and also at the same time some tips on
what you can do to make your transition
from military to civilian smoother so
before I get into today's episode about
military transition to civilian life if
this is your first time visiting this
channel this the number one channel on
YouTube for entrepreneurs if you've
never subscribed to the channel please
do so we got over a thousand videos on
business great interviews lots of tips
lots of strategies so you can subscribe
and after this video you can watch some
of the other videos let me get right
into so point number one for military
transition into civilian life rule
number one a lot of times in the
military we are indirectly taught that
civilian people are not as good as us
and I know this kind of sounds strange
to people that I've never been in the
military before if you've been in the
military military looks down to
civilians sometimes because it's kind of
like they don't work as hard as we do
they don't put their life on the line do
you realize what we do and we are fed
this in the military so much so
sometimes the biggest challenge military
faces transitioning is respecting
civilians that you may work for because
indirectly if you don't respect the boss
or somebody you're working as a
supervisor you're gonna have a hard time
working with them and they're gonna feel
it and you're gonna feel it so rule
number one when you're leaving the
military civilians are not the enemy
point number two if you are married
things get a little bit weird when you
leave the military so when you're in the
military you got formation early in the
morning you know you're working too late
at night a lot
you maybe at the motor pool or the
office or s1 or whatever you're doing
you're gonna stay there late and then on
the weekends you may have to go to the
field sometimes you got you're being
deployed so you don't you may not see
your spouse your wife or your husband
regularly when you get out in the
civilian world you're gonna see them
pretty much every day and that part may
be good and bad but initially it's
exciting and then eventually it's a
little bit annoying and it's kind of
like your wife may want you to leave and
go get a job or do something your
husband may leave and go out there and
do something I know this sounds like a
strange analogy it's like what happens
when an NFL or an NBA athlete is done
playing professional for 10 years and
all of a sudden they're transitioning
into a regular life because now the wife
is there all the time
Eddie George was just earlier today
former Heisman Trophy winner and former
Rookie of the Year he's talking about
the fact that when he was done with the
NFL he had no idea what - because his
wife was there all the time and it's
like dude why are you here all the time
so as you're transitioning and if you're
married
things are gonna get a little weird give
it 3 6 12 months eventually things will
smooth out don't over react and make a
sudden decision for yourself give it 12
months it's gonna get smoother pond
number 3 is for single folks if you're
single not married
don't even think about getting married
if you're still in a military
transitioning out till you're 30 years
old take your time there is no hurry out
there to get mirror I know a lot of
people gonna tell you look again this is
my opinion you may not have to listen to
me some other people may give you a
different argument but there is this you
know a stereotype that military folks
get out where they meet a girl
they don't use a condom they get a
pregnant then they get married then they
realize marriage doesn't work then they
get deployed then get they get divorced
and they get a DUI then they get out of
the army or the Marines or whatever
maybe if you can figure out a way to
minimize that do so so don't get
emotional when you by yourself and just
because you meet somebody you decided to
get married because all your problems
are gonna be solved they're not if you
get married and you have a kid problems
will actually get bigger in your life so
if you can wait till 30 years old to
make that decision do so point number
four don't be macho let me explain to
what I mean by domi macho look this is
coming from a guy that most people that
know me will tell
I'm an a-type personality type a and
he's macho he's diss you know Latinos
may call me and machismo because its
Patrick with David he's so this
sometimes when you get out of the
military or you're in about to
transition out and you were deployed
okay I've had good friends who were
deployed and they came back and you
still got things you're dealing with you
saw stuff you it's tough for you right
don't set it aside go talk to somebody
go find the counselor go find another
sergeant or an officer that's willing to
listen
there are many of those counselors now
they speak to somebody before you get
out because if you hang on to it and
then you get out what are you gonna do
come talk to civilians and explain your
pain not everyone's gonna understand you
you may as well take advantage of
whatever the military offers you right
now to talk to them before you leave but
the one thing you definitely cannot do
is just try to internalize it because
sometimes imploding is worse than
exploding it's better to explode in
front of somebody and cry and say I
don't know what to do I saw what
happened in war it was emotional I lost
a buddy that's 10 times better than
imploding here because this can have
ramifications on everybody around you
including yourself go talk to counselor
about the issues that you're having with
PTSD and any of that stuff don't think
it's embarrassing to talk about it it's
a real issue go talk to someone about it
point number five there's gonna be a few
things you're gonna need to unlearn now
let me explain to what it is here's a
few things got to unload the whole
formalities of yes sir
yes ma'am yes yes sir in a military very
normal in civilian it's kind of
uncomfortable for some civilians to
counsel II hear that right the other one
is acronyms military's filled with
acronyms right when you come out and use
all these acronyms the average person
civilian person doesn't understand what
you're talking about maybe military does
but the average person does not next one
is the time hey what time do you need me
here 1700 I'll be here at 1700 no no not
1700 I'll be there are five o'clock in
the afternoon
okay great you know I'll get off at
seven o'clock this afternoon not 1900
that jargon is confusing for civilians
the next one military let me put it to
you this way I probably dropped the
f-bomb I don't know five hundred times a
day in the military on any
when I got out I worked at Bally Total
Fitness there was a guy named Fernando
there and one day he sits me down says
Patrick do you realize how much you
curse I said what are you talking about
he says every adjective of yours is that
that that is it's so much that you kind
of scare some people a little bit you're
all so big you dropping f-bombs man you
may want to kind of bring it down a
little bit and change some of the
cursing and this guy was a friend he
ended up being one of my groomsmen on my
wedding but he kind of gave me that
inside you know what that part makes
sense okay fair enough
I'll consider that and I toned it out a
little bit of the profanity the next
part the temper tantrum military there's
a lot of temper tantrum soldier I told
you Papa Papa fine military it's normal
culture in the military not in the
civilian world you've got to kind of
tone it down when you're making that
transition some of those things you
gotta unlearn as you're making a
transition from military to civilian
point number six is one foot in one foot
out
let me explain to what I mean by this so
sometimes when you're out you're in the
civilian world you're not really out in
the back of your mind you're like if
this doesn't work in the next three
months guess what I'm gonna reenlist
okay so for me said I'm gonna try this
but I'm gonna realize but we don't talk
about this to everybody but we think
about in the back of the - why because
military is warm and fuzzy formation
shall run PT you know go to a formation
again you know uh you know chow boom
barracks you coming out field you know
MRE px all these things is like that
that you're used to and we like it
because it's trust it's predictable it's
like there's a routine someone's telling
you what to do and it creates a lot of
comfort and Trust I fully understand
that part right but if you come out and
you have dreams and you want to pursue
them and one foot is back in to want to
re-enlist and you're doing that it ain't
gonna happen
if you comin out you got to come out of
make it work don't look back you made a
decision to get out make it work no more
looking back look forward on what you
can do next it won't be easy the first
three six twelve months but many have
done it so can you point number seven
lack of finances let's talk about
finance this year so sometimes when
you're about to ETS my suggestion to you
there's going to be so many more power
oh my gosh we're gonna go out this
weekend because Johnson's getting out
you know hey this let's go out this okay
Peter six-pack case bow Jack Jim Joe hey
Mona this is great I'm drinking I'm
having so much fun and you get out and
you're broke and if you're broke you
panic even more when you're trying to
get a job let me give you a tip go to
fewer drinking parties fewer cases fewer
six-packs fewer jacked gym whatever you
want to call all of that tequila
whatever Jose's just fewer that save
save save save save any way you can to
save save because when you get out the
fact that you have a cushion will make
you make a better decision on a career
than one that's desperate that the first
one you have to say yes to a little bit
of savings helps you make a better
decision on which career site to go to
point number eight don't go on
disability just because everybody tells
you to go on disability okay so let's
talk about this this one's a little bit
controversial some of you're gonna agree
some of you're gonna disagree with this
so I have friends that when we were in
they were never deployed they never went
anywhere they never were at a tough unit
nothing crazy happened to them but right
before he testing their peers tell him
hey guess what what's that Tyler got 25%
what do you mean he got 25% for the rest
of his life because he won and he says
his back hurts and they signed it in and
he reported to the their wedding and a
poem he's getting 25% of us guess what
such-and-such got 50% no yeah the other
guy put a back brace he got 75% that's
awesome bro not a fan of it I have
friends who get disability for the rest
of their lives yes for what reasons
because they were deployed four six
eight years and it totally had an impact
on their lives and they served 20 years
fine
absolutely that person deserves that
because they sacrifice 20 years of their
life but there's too many people that
are trying to work the system here's why
I discourage you from doing that let me
explain to you why the reason why I
discourage you from doing that it's not
because you're stealing money from the
government forget about that it's
because you feel you are disabled and
you are being given money to
do that it messes with your character it
messes with your psyche how are you
gonna go out and also build a business
or go become successful in the company
when you're getting disability that you
don't deserve if that is unaligned the
problem is here
not out there if you have something
broke your back broke your knees
something happened happens all the time
I fully get it well deserved you got it
some happen to you while you were in the
military with government property but if
you try to work the system you gonna be
unaligned you're not gonna feel good if
characters not good here you're not
gonna be a line on the outside you're
not gonna get good results so don't take
advantage the system it's gonna hurt you
at the end so we just talked about some
of the challenges you face as you're
leaving the military to become a
civilian right okay so that's the
challenges that I could go create 30
different at them but I'm just giving
you a few them here let's talk about how
to make the transition effective number
one way before you're getting out find
out every unit you're at there's a few
things that happen there's always the
three four or five names that you knew
who transition out who are doing very
good for themselves stay in contact with
them message them consistently ask them
what happened what did you do what
worked what didn't work what blind spots
what concerns should I have how do I
handle this and if you're married talk
to a guy that was married that guy that
worked if you're single talk to a person
that got out that was single but stay
very close and connected to the people
who transition out and it was a
successful transition that's point
number one
tip number two find military groups to
be a part of and what I mean by military
groups you can go on LinkedIn you can go
on Facebook you know somebody different
places pose your question look at the
articles read the blogs get closer to
them find out who the administrators
there's one military group I was just
invited to called elite meet and this is
ran by former Navy SEAL who he was
getting out he was having anxiety he
didn't know what to do and he created
that elite meet and it's for former Navy
SEAL black ops you know Green Beret
Delta all these guys they go part of
this group and they help them with job
placement and even want to go over here
there's a job in New York talk to this
person and within it they're helping
each other on there's a lot of
sponsorship find different groups to be
a part of those groups typically you may
find a contact that's going to help you
with a job placement point number three
don't necessarily take
career paths that everyone tells you to
take here's what I mean by it if you're
a veteran you know what happens when you
get out of the military if you work at
the UPS you get additional ten points on
a test
so what go be a cop that's what
everybody does because to me they offer
me to be a cop at Fort Lauderdale Mall
because they were needing cops for Fort
Lauderdale mall at the time and this was
1999 I almost took it for 32 grand go be
a firefighter go be this so all of these
things is what they tell you that may
not be your next move because if
everybody is going through some same
places and you're going there as well
what is the specialty about you find
other places that veterans are not
looking at go to those places that want
somebody like you you have a higher
chance getting hired here with a better
career than where everybody else is
going tip number four find industries
and companies who specialize in hiring
veterans many companies nowadays they
will say we hire veterans last year we
hired 100,000 veterans last year we hire
200 veterans last year we are at 500
veterans excellent that's great to know
go search find those companies that who
they are
find the HR rep find a person that's
hiring send them an email hey my name is
this I get out of the military in nine
months I wanted to be proactive and send
a message out to you letting you know
that I read the history of your company
and I noticed you support veterans I
would like to speak to about the
possibility of working with your company
when I leave the military can I please
have a phone call with you this is my
resume reach out and do some research to
find out what companies are hiring
veterans there's many of them send
emails to them eventually one of them
may work out for you tip number five
reach out to influencers who are former
veterans this one's self-explanatory
look there's a lot of influencers that
were former veterans send them a message
hey this is what I'm doing what do you
think I ought to do you know here's
where I'm at I know you're a veteran
thank you for your service I'm about to
get out I'm a marine I notice you're a
marine what do you suggest I do hear and
see what kind of help they can get maybe
they know somebody to refer you to
that's gonna help you with a job or help
you with a curry or give you a reference
or give you some direction or pudding to
put you in contact with another
influencer that may be a good thing for
you but there are many influences out
there that are former veterans reach out
to them
many cases they're willing to help out
their fellow veterans and last but not
least feel comfortable self-promoting
your military background
let me explain to what I mean by this I
get out of the military I'm trying to
get a job I apply to Morgan Stanley Dean
Witter which requires a four-year degree
but I apply with no four-year degree no
to your degree I make it to third
interview with Dave Kirby the branch
office manager I'm sitting here the
other person that's also fighting for
the job is sitting to my left her name
is Sol I'm Patrick mid David here's Dave
Kirby he says why don't you present your
business plan
she starts I'll go first by the way I
got a 1560 on my SAT out of 1600 I went
to UC Berkeley did a four-year program
in two and a half years I ran one of the
biggest clubs in UC Berkeley while I was
still going to school and here's what my
game plan would be as an advisor first
quarter dry cleaners second quarter
doctor's third quarter car wash owners
she opens up and tells him the schedule
and his cat her calendar he's like oh my
gosh she's amazing so I'm sitting there
saying oh my goodness what the hell am I
gonna say
okay here's my story so Patrick what's
your plants and honestly I don't want
page business plan okay and what might
one page business plan said I'm gonna
talk to everybody three foot roll and
all this other stuff but here's what I
said I said mr. Kirby first of all thank
you for the opportunity to sit down here
and interview with you one thing I will
tell you as a former veteran we know how
to work hard we know how to find
solutions we don't do a lot of
complaining we figure ways out to do
things better and we get to work and you
know it matters to us to go out there
and protect people it's one of the
things we do in military we are wired to
protect and in the investment world we
get paid to also make sure we protect
people's investments and we watch over
them it's one of the things we
specialize in if you give me an
opportunity I promise you I want to get
to work
pause he looks at her says you're hired
you're gonna get this position and then
we're gonna talk about what the offer is
gonna be for you but you're hired great
because it was only one job one person
that we're looking for and he says
Patrick you're also hired she says what
he doesn't
are you gonna hire she said this like
she couldn't control herself but we
became good friends afterwards says yeah
I like you as well as a veteran you're
hard-working everything you said makes
sense I want to give you the opportunity
I said I'm all-in couple months later I
become a series 7 broker than 66th and
31 then 26 then life and out fast
forward 18 years later I'm still in the
financial industry now I'm running my
own agency we got 11,000 agents
nationwide 49 states 100 plus offices
but my career started at Morgan Stanley
Dean Witter when dave kirby gave me a
job just because of my military
background so if you're watching this
self-promote a little bit talk about
what things you did talk about how big
the project was talk about how many
hours you work talk about how
disciplined you are talk about your PT
score talk about all that stuff because
they're not just hiring you to know a
lot about numbers and things like this
they're hiring you as a leader as a
person that has soft skills as a person
that has hard skills they're hiring the
entire package sell it don't hesitate
don't second-guess sell yourself sell
yourself and eventually opportunities
will be out there and someone's going to
sound like this person's approach come
on board so now you have an idea what to
anticipate while you're transitioning
from military life to civilian life as
well as what you do to kickstart your
next career by the way I made a video a
few years ago titled 19 military lessons
that made me Millions here's a thumbnail
of it if you haven't watched it click on
us to watch it there's a lot of good
things that you can learn from that and
last but not least if you've got another
veteran you may be a veteran you're
saying man I got peers that need to
watch this as they're about to ETS share
this video with them it may give them
some tips to anticipate while they're
ETS Inc out of the military
having said that thank you for your
service and if you haven't subscribed to
the channel please do so take everybody
bye-bye